you look at papers and people are really
Keen they draw this curve and they have
these you know these bars on the curve
and things it's just this curve and it's
this one thing and it's supposed to
represent some system that has all kinds
of details in it and this is a way that
lots of science has gotten wrong because
people say I remember years ago I was
studying snowflake growth you know you
have a snowflake and it's growing it has
all these arms it's doing complicated
things but there was a literature on
this stuff and it talked about you know
what's the rate of snowflake growth and
you know it got pretty good answers for
the rate of the growth of the Snowflake
and they looked at it more carefully and
they had these nice curves of you know
snowflake growth rates and so on I
looked at it more carefully and I
realized according to their models the
snowflake will be spherical
and so they got the growth rate right
but the detail was just utterly wrong
and you know not only the detail the the
whole thing was was not capturing you
know it was capturing this aspect of the
system that was in a sense missing the
main point of was going on and what is
the geometric uh shape of a snowflake
snowflakes start in in the phase of
water that's relevant to the formation
of snowflakes it's a phase of ice which
starts with a hexagonal arrangement of
water molecules and so it starts off
growing as a hexagonal plate and then
what happens is it's the plate oh oh
versus sphere well no no but it's it's
much more than that I mean snowflakes
are fluffy you know typical snowflakes
have little little dendritic arcs yeah
and what actually happens is it's kind
of kind of cool because you can make
these very simple discrete models with
cellular automata and things that that
figure this out you start off with this
you know hexagonal thing and then the
places it starts to grow little arms and
every time a little piece of ice it adds
itself to the snowflake the fact that
that ice condensed from the water vapor
heats the snowflake up locally and so it
makes it less likely for uh for another
piece of ice to accumulate right nearby
so this leads to a kind of growth
inhibition so you grow an arm and it is
a separated arm because right around the
arm it got a little bit hot and it
didn't add more ice there so what
happens is it grows you have a hexagon
it grows out arms the arms go arms and
then the arms go arms go arms and
eventually actually it's kind of cool
because it actually fills in another
hexagon a bigger hexagon and when I
first looked at this we had a very
simple model for this I realized you
know when it fills in that hexagon it
actually leaves some holes behind so I
thought well you know that is that
really right so look at these pictures
of snowflakes and sure enough they have
these little holes in them that are kind
of scars of the way that these arms grow
out
um so you can't fill in backfill holes
yeah they don't backfill and presumably
there's a limitation of how big like you
can't arbitrarily grow
I'm not sure I mean the thing falls
through the the I mean I think it this
you know it hits the ground at some
point I think you can grow I think you
can grow in the lab I think you can grow
pretty big ones I think you can grow
many many iterations of this kind of
goes from hexagon it grows out arms it
turns back it fills back into a hexagon
it grows more arms again in 3D no it's
flat usually
why is it flat why doesn't it uh span
out okay okay wait a minute you said
it's fluffy and fluffy is a
three-dimensional property no or no it's
it's fluffy snow is okay so you know
what makes we're really uh we're really
in it
but there's multiple snowflakes become
fluffy a single snowflake is not fluffy
no no single snowflake is Fluffy and
what happens is you know if if you have
snow that it's just pure hexagons they
they can you know they they fit together
pretty well it's not it doesn't it
doesn't make it doesn't have a lot of
air in it and they can also slide
against each other pretty easily and so
the snow can be pretty you know can I
think avalanches happen sometimes when
when the things tend to be these you
know hexagonal plates and it kind of
slides but then when the thing has all
these arms that have grown out it's not
they don't fit together very well and
that's why the snow has lots of air in
it and if you look at one of these
snowflakes and if you catch one you'll
see it has these little arms and people
actually people often say you know no
two snowflakes are alike
um that's mostly because as a snowflake
grows they do grow pretty consistently
with these different arms and so on but
you capture them at different times as
they you know they fell through through
the air in a different way you'll catch
this one at this stage and as it goes
through different stages they look
really different and so that's why you
know kind of looks like no two slime
flakes are alike because you caught them
at different at different times so the
rules under which they grow are the same
it's just the timing is yes okay so the
point is science is not able to uh
describe the full complexity of
snowflake growth well science if you if
you do what people might often do just
say okay let's make it scientific let's
turn into one number and that one number
is kind of the growth rate of the arms
or some such other thing that fails to
capture sort of the detail of what's
going on inside the system and that's in
a sense a big challenge for science is
how do you extract from the natural
world for example those aspects of it
that you are interested in talking about
now you might just say I don't really
care about the fluffiness of the
snowflakes all I care about is the
growth rate of the arms in which case
you know you have you can have a good
model without knowing anything about the
fluffiness
um but the fact is as a practical you
know when if you if you say what's the
what is the most obvious feature of a
snowflake oh that it has this
complicated shape well then you've got a
different story about what you model I
mean this is one of the features of sort
of modeling and science that you know
what is a Model A model is some way of
reducing the actuality of the world to
something where you can readily sort of
give a narrative for what's happening
where you can basically make some kind
of abstraction of what's happening and
answer questions that you care about
answering if you want to answer all
possible questions about the system
you'd have to have the whole system
because you might care about this
particular molecule where did it go and
you know your model which is some big
abstraction of that has nothing to say
about that so you know one of the things
that's that's often confusing in science
is people will have I've got a model
somebody says somebody else will say I
don't believe in your model because it
doesn't capture the feature of the
system that I care about you know
there's always this controversy about
you know is the is it a correct model
well no model is a except for the actual
system itself is a correct model in the
sense that it captures everything
questions does It capture what you care
about capturing sometimes that's
ultimately defined by what you're going
to build technology out of things like
this the one counter example to this is
if you think you're modeling the whole
universe all the way down then there is
a notion of a correct model but even
that is more complicated because it
depends on kind of how observers sample
things and so on that's a that's a
separate story but at least at the first
level to say you know this thing about
oh it's an approximation you're
capturing one aspect you're not
capturing other aspects when you really
think you have a complete model for the
whole universe you better be capturing
ultimately everything even though to
actually run that model is impossible
because of computational reducibility
the only the only thing that
successfully runs that model is the
actual running of the universe